this is the greatest country on Earth
among our natural resources and endless
supply of idiots they're everywhere you
don't even need to frack him here's a
week's worth right here first up Liz
Warren otherwise known as chief
spreading bull after years of being
accused of lying about her Native
American background she decides to take
a DNA test creating a video around
laughable results the president likes to
call my mom a liar what are the facts
say you absolutely have an American
ancestor in your pedigree hmm wow that
looked totally natural if she got any
stiffer I'd check for the toe tag talk
about a pale face it's telling that they
chose us some Stanford academic to
finesse these terrible results they just
knew they were about to paint a turd
orange and college sherbert because when
the results arrived it amounted to
something between nearly zero and nearly
zero like point zero nine if your IQ was
point zero nine you would be granite if
they gave her a breathalyzer she'd be
over the legal limit of stupid as a wise
man once said when it comes to Cherokee
she has more in common with the Jeep
maybe she can be their spokesman
the slogan unlike me this Cherokee is
not fully so think about what she pulled
off one law school directory listed her
as Native American for nine years
Harvard had her as Native American until
2004 she was called Harvard laws first
woman of color and then there was the
cookbook powwow Chow recipes from five
Indian tribes she listed herself as
Cherokee
yeah and I'm Bjorn from ABBA
actually I did some research to find out
who has more Native American blood than
her here they are
Bjorn from ABBA Agnetha from ABBA
and a freed from ABBA and the other guy
from ABBA
hard to believe I actually did even more
research to find out who has more Native
American blood than her flipper my
office stapler this helmet so we spent a
long time being lectured by left-wing
a-holes about what not to wear on
Halloween better not wear a sombrero
amigo hands off the headdress cultural
appropriation is so evil but by all
means says our leading libs totally
claim ownership of an entire culture and
exploited for political purposes
seriously hasn't worn committed the
biggest cultural appropriation sin ever
she stole who they are now I can talk
because I am two percent Native American
it's true that's more Indian than she is
meaning I'm Native American I know what
I'm going as for Halloween
could could this be the end of identity
politics if DNA tests reveal that you
contain the same amount of oppressed
ancestry that liz has then your
oppressed too if everyone's a minority
that nobody is except me as you know I
did do my own DNA test on the five and
then I made a video
hi I'm Greg Gutfeld my ancestry is
incredibly rich remember the Donner
Party
that's my great-great-grandfather Karl
he never went hungry I'm proud of my
family's roots so I decided to take a
DNA test the results were fascinating
turns out I'm 40 point 8 percent British
and Irish 9% Iberian 2% Native American
and 20% Minotaur and 20% giant Sequoia
yeah one of my granddad's had a thing
for trees I'm also 30% centur which
explains why it's hard to get jeans that
fit there's also a bit of sea serpent in
there about 90% at this point I know
what you're thinking that adds up to
more than 100% well it's two hundred and
twelve point three percent to be exact
how can that be well I'll tell you
[Music]
or fair the wrath of my endless
mutilations as I tear at the products of
your naked cowering loved ones
Bell 2020 made for by the committee to
elect slark don't applaud that
monstrosity that was really unexpected
so anyway the other idiot this week the
litigating lollipop Michael a vanetti
the dome dope had been using various
victims to attract the spotlight for
himself but when he finally finds the
spotlight this happens this week the
judge ruled in favor of Donald Trump and
Stormies defamation case against him and
ordered that she paid Trump's legal fees
this was the judges way of telling
stormy that her lawyer is giving lawyers
a bad name think about that she's a porn
star and her lawyers so bad
suddenly her career looks respectable
she used to get paid to screw people a
vanetti just screwed her and she has to
pay him he he is two lawyers what Liz
Warren is to Indians and embarrassment
so it's really been a week of backfiring
everything blew up in their faces the
DNA test exposes Warren as point zero
Indian the judge exposes a vanetti as
100% bozo meanwhile the u.s. regains its
spot as the number one competitive
economy in the world and US job openings
hit a record 7.1 million exceeding the
number of unemployed Americans pretty
soon you're gonna need a DNA test to
prove you're an unemployed American
that's pretty good for Trump but it may
not be good enough for Liz Warren and a
vanetti there may be seven million job
openings but we still have at least two
more idiots than we need
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guest
he's the prescription for your
affliction host of the radio show doctor
true midday live dr. Drew Pinsky he
split more sides than a butcher on meth
comedian Jimmy fela not used to that
jacket
she's the pinnacle of cynical national
review reporter cat Tim and he always
has his head in the clouds literally
warm former WWE Superstar my massive
sidekick Tyrus dr. drew you're a doctor
what did Senator Warren accidentally do
to herself this week other than shoot
herself in the foot yes you know I've
found through on the rear program I had
a number of northern Native Americans
call us and say each tribe determines
its own criteria for heritage right and
it's usually between 1/8 and 1/16 but
for Cherokee particularly you have to
register with the Indian Affairs
Department and you have to be able to
show your heritage back to a given
individual in order to call yourself
Cherokee and they were deeply offended
by this deeply offended talking about
I'll say appropriation it was the
ultimate appropriate they tried to steal
she tried to steal their identity its
Jimmy it's an outrage yes not as
outrageous as this jacket I know I'm
from make did you buy that at just chess
King or merry-go-round this is my uh
this is my oldest guy in the boy band
look I look like the guy they won't fire
because I can buy them beer after the
show yeah what do you call the boots ah
they do come in men's if you want her
right Shepherd would love those I
actually do think she disqualified
herself right the reason I say that is
not because of anything Trump's gonna do
but because of what her own party is
going to do in the primaries nobody's
tougher on you when you screw up then
your friends you don't mean
so all like the time you said you were a
Native American like she's never gonna
live this down for the rest of her life
and then you know he's gonna go after
her I mean Joe Biden must be so he must
be wow you must be pleased as punch
Kamala Harris I'll throw a Booker I mean
did she's gone I don't think there's any
way she can come back and you want to
know
why she should go away it's not because
she lied it's because she outed herself
as dumb yeah anyone who thought anyone
who thought this was acceptable proof
based on the results let her do this is
like telling someone we have a really
hot girlfriend but the only picture in
your wallet is clearly from a magazine
hey you know what I only did that once
cat for your birthday you were going to
be showing up in a coffin so you were
appropriating the lifestyle of the dead
you're as bad as she is I'm dead on the
inside so this story I mean I was
sitting around my apartment earlier this
week shocking I know and I was thinking
the only friend that I have that lives
close to me anywhere in this city is a
cat yes right horse like I wake up
there's the cat right you know during
the day there's the cat I go to bed
there's the cat cat feels off Liz Warren
if Liz Warren is one 1024 Native
American I've got to be at least one
1,024 cat yes yes not the time that I
spend around the cat and if you don't
think that cat human culture is a thing
it is definitely a thing yeah yeah yeah
we walk around with clothes covered in
it like people don't notice no I noticed
we buy frozen meals for one yes
we own wine Stoppers yes like who are we
kidding I know that's true
wishful thinking
Pyrus where do we go with this
I'm guys with you I checked out when the
green dudes showed up you have lost your
damn mind
lorig are you talking about this large
large
yeah that was like this damn man like
what the hell I don't start eating
people cuz I can't handle that
don't Dahmer on me I can safely say I
probably didn't write that sober yeah
listen this is this is what this these
are these days that I'm so happy I
didn't have grandparents because it was
her lionize grandparents who got her in
this mess
especially everyone's got the your
great-grandfather was chair he was a
chief Cherokee Indian how many people
heard that damn lion a story in there
inaudible like everybody says the same
thing and just one mm-hmm
white people are can only be one yeah
more than two year out the game but
there's always that one and she believed
papa whatever weird nickname she had for
grandpa who told her that drunk ass line
story so much so that I'm pretty sure
her team was like this is not a good
idea
godo my grandfather told me it is true
yes and now we have to deal with not
only is she not Native American which I
kind of think she already really knew
yeah cuz no one ever like made jokes
there was no teasers going on right
right but now she has to face the
President of the United States of
America yes every time they're in the
hallway he's gonna be like hey stop
[Laughter]
guaranteed
yeah I was just thinking whoever let her
put that up must be the same person let
you put this large video is amazing no
it's Saturday night and right now she's
home shocked that she didn't win the
Mega Millions she thinks one in three
hundred and two million is good chance
let's end on that great joke
[Applause]